what about [ __ ]
all jermaine sterling
like
what about him it's such a big question
you know like he should change his name
to
i'm just here for the comments
yeah he's kind of got a it's tough
because he's he's one of the best in the
world like in the banter is he the champ
yeah he's the champion of the dq
but he was clearly getting worse okay
then they last just fight for the
interim belt who
and then uh then he fought against it
was really weird that san hagen got that
interim belt i didn't think so i didn't
think so because i thought he beat tj
he's he's very he's like i mean if you
ask
the mma community like do you think he's
deserving of it every one of them would
have said yes as far as his skill what
he's done in the bantamweight division
um i i thought it was thought it thought
it was well deserved i mean it was
tricky because tj beat him but he
couldn't fight aljo pulled out because
his neck it's like who's the next guy
rob font and jose aldo are already
fighting like he was the next guy
and he it was a really sweet fight
himbers peter lit um but al joe yeah
poor al joe is like
comments are just [ __ ]
it's roasting him i think they're
getting to him obviously i think i mean
it's just gnarly because he now he's
like
trying to like bring on hate you know i
mean i guess he was as soon as
as soon as he started like posing with
the belt
it's like what else are you gonna do you
can't fight the comments cause they're
all true you know
so much just it's just i mean it's kind
of bumming me out the way that he's like
just trying to turn everybody against
him is what it looks like yeah and it's
and it doesn't like what matters is his
next performance like he's got to go out
there and beat peter he's got to and i
mean
looking back at their last fight it's
gonna be a tough task peter
out wrestled him out struck him out
cardioed him out game planned him
besides the [ __ ] knee obviously but
uh i i'm not counting aljo out of that
fight algae was a top bantamweight his
grappling is his very high level his
cardio like it was more of like a game
plan like you can't come out like a spaz
like that against peter young as a
[ __ ] killer who's
did just like
to beat corey the same way jose the same
way
like he comes out there very tight
defense very good defense and and kind
of lets you
use a lot of energy in the first couple
rounds and then picks it up like and al
joe completely [ __ ] used all of his
energy in the early rounds and then
completely gassed out so i think it was
a game plan error um but i'm not
counting him out of that fight i think
you know especially he's got to win that
fight he's got to go out there and win
that fight
um and shut everybody or the
comments are literally just gonna be
worse
yeah
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude